[Music]
you two look
incredible you walked out and I felt
inferior and in the moment that I saw
you you look fantastic I am so excited
that you both are here I'm such a fan of
both of you we've gotten to talk before
you are new here I have to ask though
everybody we such huge fans shed Creek
so where's Voice come from like how did
you decide uh actually I knew I I I
think originally it was written sort of
a little more smartass and kind of
calling Eugene's character on getting us
in the situation giving him hard and
very funny but um I just thought I'd
seen that done so well by other people
that I was and so I would wanted to be
more feminine well been done by you in
Beetlejuice by the way the mother was
kind of a smart kind of yeah but when I
argue I feel like I get really harsh and
stuff and I just want awesome and but I
know a woman who is so feminine and I
thought that what a great way to go just
be soft and keep the mouth moving softly
yeah
just it's surreal it's surreal so
incredible I I've been very excited
about this moment anyway do you ever
take inspiration from like real people
that you know for characters um you know
sometimes things are just sort of like
obvious and make sense and there was one
time um I was doing a movie and um yeah
notic someone uh did something quite
awful and their walk just made sense for
this character that I played in the help
and so um oh my God what a great You'
have been in so many great films oh so
it was yeah no it was a it was a walk
yeah and it was and everyone who knew
this person knew that it was I love the
hidden joke as well that's amazing well
speaking of walking you got a lot of
your like physical comedy from your dad
right I did yeah it was some kind of
walk right the yeah I did A Walk in the
end of beston show where uh I hurt my
knee and and the day before we you know
it was improvised movie but it was all
in the script everything all the outline
except dialogue and the night before uh
Chris said what are we going to do when
Chris guest said what are you going to
do when we fall I said there's this walk
my dad would do could I try he let me
see it and he just said oh yes yes so we
my dad would walk ahead of us going into
church or going into a mall or something
we'd all laugh and everyone in the every
one of the seven kids in our family does
the walk but I got to do it in a movie
yeah you got to be the first that's a
lot of siblings yeah six yeah that's
where the humor comes
in you have to you have to laugh my mom
and dad laughed every day it was so
great and sexy oh I I agree I agree well
speaking of family Bryce uh shared this
old photo so we're going to put that
look okay where are you there you know
what I don't even like really know
necessarily but you're winking at us oh
am I oh no I'm you know what it is I'm
like I'm very sensitive to Sun so yes so
it's very likely that I just couldn't
see anything yeah but I my family um uh
we always go on road trips that's always
the thing that I would do kind of like
growing up and it would always be these
these road trips um and um uh no one
enjoyed them except for my mother uh and
forced family fun yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like the second thing like car door
was shut we knew that like there was no
escaping for at least six and a half
hours and so just like did you bring the
bananas with you like it was like very
intense but um it was you know like
there were there were definitely
definitely a lot of great memories and
then and then there were a few weird
ones one time my parents were driving
from LA to eede and they left my
11-year-old brother in a Crispy Cream in
Los Angeles and it took them four hours
to figure it out and they arrived in
eane and four hours four hours what kind
of therapy has this one been through I
know I know well actually I really good
as a mother now I know like it's very
home alone actually totally Home Alone
leaving the kid that was that was
reasonable that was
no no four hours four hours a Crispy
Cream it's a nice place to H wor plac 8
hours because my parents needed to drive
back to to get him and my mom cried the
entire time and they show up and my you
it's a little stereotypical so I
apologize if I offend anyone he was
surrounded by cops and they were all
eating Donuts together
it's what it is fine I mean we all eat
donuts not just cops they're good yeah
especially when you get there and
they're warm I mean I've
heard so their new movie is called Argy
it's in theaters and IMAX Nationwide
starting tomorrow so before we get to
Argo because we I don't even know how
we're going to explain it without
spoiling it but before we get to that I
heard that there is a Beetle Juice too
possibly there is
yeah well I heard do you actually met
your husband husband on the set of
Beetle Juice I did yeah he was a
production designer designed all those
wild sets and and they actually did U
redid the whole house on the same Hill
in Vermont for the second for the second
one um but he yeah he was talking to me
every day it was like high school just
talking to me every day like by our
lockers and then he never asked me out
and then he went on to prep the stuff in
in uh Vermont and I'm grousing to Tim
Burton about how the production design
never asked me and I said let me see
what I can do and I got there first day
of shooting there BS off to the side but
wel is his name he comes our um you like
to go to the art Department's going to
swamp meet you want to come with us wow
like you been forced really reeling you
in yeah I guess but Tim was right made
it happen I love that you got set up
this is um actually for some reason
tracks for me but like as a gift a
wedding gift he gave you a tour of the
Vatican Tim did yeah a private no
private okay but I'm just like that is
the most random wedding gift I've ever
heard of it's how possible had given it
to him I don't know it's a very inside
kind of deal what was that we okay a
priest took us around he got yelled at
at one point I wish I spoke aali but he
was definitely getting yelled at by
another priest because we were in the
Pope's closet like looking at garments
it was crazy we were in the the elevator
that he takes down to St peters's
Basilica to do Mass we were in this
lovely little um uh uh like a tiny
Museum where all the gifts to the
Vatican from every country in the from
every country leader in the world uh
gifts that had been sent to the Vatican
since the beginning of the VA and this
priest is letting us open cases and
pretending to put a crown inside Bose's
backpack taking pictures I wish I had
those pictures with me just crazy you
don't have these pictures somewhere I do
oh man that's amazing yeah but what a
yeah it was beautiful gift it's such a
random GI I'm very memorable I'll give
them that that you were rumaging around
the Pope's closet as one does that's
like when you're like to say this so
loud going to like real estate or
something and you're like oh I'm just
going to go like walk open houses and
you're just going to peek around a
little bit no
yes I will take it I will have you what
were your wedding gifts like any
comparison there well I made I don't
want to say I made a mistake I don't
regret it but I was one of the first uh
or the first person of my group to kind
of get married my husband was 24 I was
25 yeah and um and at the time we were
like you know vegan raw foodists and
very much so you vote with your dollar
and all that and so it was a wedding of
like um in lie of gifts right in lie of
gifts might you donate to or consider
something that's beautiful it was great
except for now like I still don't have a
proper set of
dishes like there are so we realized
this we were like there are so many
things that you just as like a like a
young person you don't know to stalk
yourself with these things and it's it's
taken 20 years for us to learn how to
feed each other honestly yes I suffer
from this too you get paid for job
though you could probably afford your
dish wear now so it's like you what
that's actually I'm no higher pay for
women that's what I say no joke we need
to afford dishes this last year this
last year I finally cuz you know after
the pandemic and stuff it was sort of
like H enough is enough and um and we we
finally went out and like yeah did the
grownup thing yeah I mean I'm in my 40s
now so I am too but I'm mix matched I've
always been that way yeah yeah I don't
know it's fun I have to there's no segue
here this movie is so fun there is so
much action Argy is incredible You'
never seen anything like it okay let's
talk about first of all how do you
explain this movie without giving it
away what have you been doing on your
promo tour it's it's it's really hard
and let me just say to everyone right
now is we are intentionally withholding
reveals because we want people to go on
the ride it is so fun yeah the way we
are permitted to talk about the movie
yeah is uh it's kind of you know Matthew
vau makes these incredible like
spectacle spy extravagan of oh my gosh
also like music videos totally totally
and and so much of of like when you you
think about like spy Cinema it's it's a
fantasy I play a spy novelist she's
created um this franchise of books
called Argy Henry caval is Argyle he's
perfect it makes sense um so so my
character is trying to finish her book
Catherine plays my mother yes and so
it's um she's going her cat and her mom
are her best friends and she's on this
cat is so cute so cute she's so cute and
she's on her way to to get some support
and on a train and encounters a real spy
and then everything goes arai everything
goes R and then it keeps there's more
and more twists I loved it thank you
sense of humor too sorry it's a it's
like I mean Matthew V's done so many
great action movies but this has even
more humor and sort of making fun of
itself somebody said it's turned action
movies inside out yeah say right side up
yeah it's poking at it a bit it's really
great um one of the reasons why I was so
excited to work with Matthew was to
learn how he shoots action because what
he does is so distinctive and what I
learned is that a huge part of his
process is um a partnership with someone
named Brad Allen who very tragically uh
he's one of the best action directors in
the world um uh and he very tragically
passed away two weeks before shooting
and he had designed all of the action
sequences he passed away at the age of
48 wow and um so young very young and
the and the film is dedicated to him and
um and so really you know this is this
is a um an Ode to him and his work and
his team and these it's incredible they
are the best perform I'm not going to
run it but the gun scene whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah but yeah I was like what
yeah and they were so like a dance yes
Rockwell inspired so much of the dance
you know and so and so things kind of
kept expanding and expanding and I would
say of of all the things I did the thing
that was the hardest was definitely the
dancing for me for sure really for sure
yes oh my God it's something you take
personally I think too dancing isn't it
it's like oh no because I watch actors
that way go oh that's how you dance is
it and some people try to look cool and
some people intentionally try to look
funny like you're not going to see how I
really dance it's such a it's so it's
vulnerable it's so exposed oh my God
it's freeing
[Music]
[Applause]
though thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home